Oblivion.
Some say the best game of all time.
A game with such...
Immersive universe. You really feel like you want to be part of it.
Ni-ni-ni-ni-ni-ni-ni-ni-ni-ni-ni-ni-ni-ni-ni-nil.
And don't even get me started on the combat system.
Stop!
You violated the law. Pay the court a fine or serve your sentence.
So lately, I've been obsessing over Oblivion videos...
So I thought I'll make a video on it. That's, that's it. That's pretty much it.
*scoff*
I played this game a long time ago, and it's such an impressive game because i- it's really before its time.
Now, looking back at it,
*laughs*
It really hasn't aged well, and it's so funny to watch these
mistakes that it had because the project was so ambitious the parts of it is just bound to fuck up and mess up.
I think the parts of it is just bound to be messed up,
and we're just going to look at all the bad stuff today, but don't take my word for it take my man.
Todd
motherFuCkInG
Howard.
This beautiful man, the creator of the series. If you have not bought skyrim yet on every single
console out there, he's going to be extremely upset with you.
"'I'm going to play quarterback for the Cowboys', and I was like, 'I'm gonna make video games!'" and everyone's gonna play 'em like...
'You dork, go back to the chess club'...
Who's laughing now?
*intense music*
Yes, I was in the chess club"
*laughs*
I like how he says it so ashamed that yes, "I was in the chess club, whatever, I'm cool now!"
Trust me. I made Oblivion. It's really it's a good game.
"I think the big thing is
the AI we have in the game design the system radiant Ai that allows the people in the world to
react really
intelligently and it sort of have their own goal is so they can look at their environment around them to decide how they want to accomplish them."
So the game has...
extremely intelligent AI.
"What have we here, another plaything? You dance for me little one. Yes you will.
I'll make your corpse dance and then tear itself apart!"
*laughs*
And not just intelligent AI, AI that truly thinks for itself.
Ni-ni-ni-ni-ni-ni-ni-ni-ni-ni-ni-ni-ni-ni-ni-nil.
Ni-ni-ni-ni-ni-ni-ni-ni-ni-ni-
It was at this moment,
Jackson knew...
Such extreme,
intelligent AI that they implemented amnesia in the game.
You see here the guard kills the beggar.
*gasp*
Oh my goodness!
E-Excuse me, are you alright?
I-
By the divines...
This person is dead.
Literally me whenever I kill a person.
*laughs*
And don't even get me started on the flawless voice acting in this game. It's truly-
EXTREME
We heard the thieves broke into the Arcane university, the imperial legion compound, and the temple all on the same night!
Wait a minute, let me do that one again..
*breath*
I heard the thieves broke into the Arcane university, the imperial legion compound, and the temple all on the same night!
Take care.
Good talk.
Good talk, I tru-truly feel immersed...
WOW
I love this one 'cause it really shows the different range the voice actors can do.
"Of course its all just,
made up to give them an excuse to keep us down."
"Thank you, kind, sir."
You give 'em a coin and..
"Have you heard about that ghost of the old man that looks out into Nibin Bay each night?"
What the fuck happened? "They're calling him--" what the fuck happened after he gave him a coin? Did his balls
drop as soon as he gets money?
"Thank you kind sir!"
"Have you heard about that ghost of the old man that looks out in--"
Jesus Christ.
Apparently to save space on the game,
they had some voice actors do the same line.
If there's a line that was gonna be repeated a lot
they have one voice actor do it instead of every voice actor do it and it's putting it together as a montage.
*kiss*
Is goddamn beautiful. Here's--uh-- here's when you give them coins.
"only asking for enough to-"
"Thank you kind sir." *mimicking* Thank you kind sir.
Blessings a shadow upon. Thank you kind sir.
Blessings of Akatosh upon ye.
"Thank you kind sir."
"Blessings of the Shadow upon ye." It's so good
"Thank you kind sir"
"blessings of Stendar upon you."
Thank you kind sir,
and don't even get me started on how incredible the dungeon crawling, the quests were in this game.
"You. What are you doing here?"
"Has the council gone mad? There's no time. I'm the only one left"--You're the only one that survived--"follow me". Thank God
You're the only one that survived at least one lived.
*laughs*
*hyucks*
Truly intelligent AI.
Maybe he's fine, you know what maybe he's okay.
No, he's definitely dead. The game was so groundbreaking that you could poison people's food, feed them to him as a sleek way
to assassinate. Let's watch.
"Welcome. Have you ever heard Alga tell her tales?"
"She's the best bard I've ever met. Of course being a bard is almost as bad as being--it's you!"
*laughter*
When the edibles kick in.
So the all ate the poison apple. "Hello there,"
"UUAGH"
*laughs*
Hello there! UAAAAH
*weird dying groan*
*laughing*
Oh my God.
"Have you heard of the high elves?"
hhhheagh
bbbbbr
bbberhhgu
*laughs*
Oh Jesus Christ.
Now some may say that the dialogue in Oblivion, it's a little awkward.
I disagree 100%. it's truly beautiful, immersive,
and it makes me feel like I'm part of the world and I want to live in it.
It's the perfect, perfect dialogue. "How are you today?"
"I'm Mirabelle Monet. I run the fo'c'sle a boarding house for sailors. Sorry. I reserve my beds for Seamen" ;)
Hehehehehehehehe
Here's an example of some classic beautiful, NPC dialog there
you can listen in to and really feel like you're part of a new universe
"It's you. Hi."
"What's going on with you?" "I ran into some goblins in the woods not long ago"
"Nasty little beasts."
"Horrible things. I hear that the high elves train them. I can't imagine it."
"Bye"
"Goodbye!"
"Greetings, Argonian."
"HELLOOOO" :D
"What's going on with you?"
"Yes."
"HMMPGH"
"Heard any news from the other provinces?"
"Good bye!"
"Hello."
"Well--" There's all these like parodies of the of the dialogue I-It's so fucking good
Well, I better get going see ya
Bye
dgnnd its 3 am i don't wanna caption this, but theres only 3 more mins of the video.. *salty*
Hi! Bye! Bye!
Oh, there's so many of these. "Outgoing mail?" "You know it." "I probably set up tomorrow." "I hear that!"
I think this is the perfect one to summarize it.
"Hello, we haven't been proper-" "No."  "-introduced before I'm Michael by the way you must be Alice." "Yeah."
"Nice to meet you Alice." "You too."
"Well Alice, do you want to go to the park bench ?" "Yeah." "Thank you."
"Well Alice, it seems,
we both got autism haven't we?" "Yes." "Well, that's good to know."
"Well, I guess the truth is, I'm similar to you, Alice. It's very difficult for me to talk to people
I've not met before like yourself."
"I have to pay you compliments like..."
"For example..."
"Let me think of an example of what a compliment is." *godammit*
*laughs*
"It seems your eyes are as brown as the tree trunks."
Oh man, I'm not--uh--there's really only one way to end this. With a goddamn beautiful
adoring fan. This beautiful specimen would follow you anywhere in the game.
"Yes! Oh Great and Mighty Grand champion!
Is there something you need? Can I can carry your weapon?--He will carry- your shit--Shine your boots? Back rub,- perhaps?"
Shine your boots, and even give him a back rub. And sometimes at night,
A little slippy slippy down there if you know what I mean
Fuck this video is old. Jesus Christ
*Overly Dramatic Music*
I didn't know you can upload YouTube videos at this point.
"By Azura, by Azura, by Azura!
It's the Grand champion! I can't believe it's you, standing here!
Next to me!"
*quickscope*
NOOOOOO HO HO HO HO
uH HUHAHA
*lesser laugh*
Oblivion, everyone! The perfect game! If you haven't played it yet, I suggest you go check it out right now!
Leave a like if you enjoyed
Buy a fidget spinner, and I will see you bros--I mean sisters--
In the next video.
It's everyday bro, I said ITS EVERYDAY BRO
YOU KNOW IT'S NICK COMPTON AND MY COLLAR STAY POPPIN